the closest of friends together a
political force seen here just over two
years ago on a rare evening out both
bankers with a similar worldview both
became chancellor
now the man on the right sajid javid has
abandoned rishi sunak in favour of this
woman
liz trust
looking like she's walking in a
direction which ends in number 10
tonight in cardiff for the latest
hustings aimed at tory members
this candidate still making fresh
promises will you abolish inheritance
tax i'm someone who believes in
supporting aspiration i think that is a
conservative value that many of us in
this room will hold dear
an inheritance tax is a way to do that
so over time is that something that we
should look at of course we should
a key part of the cell isn't to the
country but to the tory party making
clear who can defeat kierstarma i
passionately believe and all the
evidence supports it that i am the
candidate that offers our party the best
opportunity to win
everywhere and ensure that kierstarma
does not walk through the doors of
number 10 downing street at the end of
that election we will be able to take on
the plastic patriot secure stammer
and we will be able to take on
the low energy version of jeremy corbyn
that is mark drakeford
and we will win
we will win my friends
pressed on scotland and her pledge to
ignore nicola sturgeon liz trust doubled
down
what's happening in scotland is the
entire resources of the scottish
government are being used to run
essentially an independence campaign and
i think that is grossly irresponsible
the scottish government are not
delivering for the people of scotland
they are simply spending their time and
nicholas sturgeon is spending her time
agitating for independence
so many of the issues at the heart of
the leadership contest so far from tax
to the size of whitehall to equality
issues have been dictated by the
candidates themselves or the divisions
between them a contest in a bubble
but what will define the person who
walks through that door on september the
6th in all likelihood are the unknowns
possibly china's attitude to taiwan or
russian further expansionism or energy
shortages
testing that
how liz trusts and richie sunak respond
to the global and domestic issues they
haven't prepared for will be at the
heart of tomorrow's special program on
sky news
final preparations here at sky
headquarters where tomorrow two
potential prime ministers will face a
studio audience of tory members who
don't know which candidate to support
sky's debate now pivotal because
security fears mean ballot only now
being sent out
sam coates sky news westminster